salut regardez qui voilà elle convient
parfaitement je te promets et elle t'a
déjà vu on y était
presque qu'est-ce qui t'arrive ne fais
pas ça blue blue non non non non non non
non
salut
oh
flute je suis trop trop content
qu'est-ce qui se passe là oui cette
question est parfaitement légitime vu ce
je suis un ai tu sais dit ami
imaginaire nos enfants ont grandi donc
il nous en faut d'autres je suis sûr que
tu pourrais nous sauver tous qui ça tous
et ne dis
pas il faut qu'il le dise sinon il a
chance que sa tête
[Applaudissements]
explose merci beaucoup tu es
prête on ne sait pas qui on trouvera
derrière cette
porte il faut qu'on les aide
absolument
[Musique]
pour laè fois enfile un pantalon c'est
gênant pour tout le
[Musique]
monde
surtout ne le regarde pas dans les yeux
je le regarde pas très bien
e merci infiniment je suis vraiment très
touché